just hanging out searching the world for
a worthy challenger
they're too intimidated by nobody wants
to play
they know what i'm telling you they see
your name and that's it they they know
how this game is going to end
in a victory for them i think i don't
know
while we're
[Music]
oh i just got a match i see oh against
fosa one from russia all right he's from
russia so that scares me
um because stereotypically i feel like
they're good
very good at chess of course russian
players pretty good
okay
okay indeed so d5 very good
standard opening moves
and d4 is a very rare guest at your your
rating the vast majority of people play
e4
they're king spawn forward are you
familiar with chess notation by the way
i don't know how much to to rely on it
uh by that do you mean like just like uh
what you said like e4 and all that kind
of stuff like the file and the yeah yeah
like like when i name
moves like bishop here bishop f5 oh
that's fine that's fine
sometimes i'll have to like look like
embarrassingly but yeah that's fine
right no that's totally fine okay so
he's
you know sometimes in the opening the
actual moves that you make aren't that
critical
as long as you're doing stuff with the
knights or bringing your pieces out
yeah yeah development that makes sense
so he's kind of screwing around a little
bit with his queen
yeah yeah you can use this opportunity
to simply continue her development he's
trying to intimidate you
yeah it doesn't seem like the most
credible threat uh
and maybe that's my famous last words
here um no
it doesn't like i'm not really scared i
don't know what that's supposed to tell
me
you shouldn't be what was the rationale
behind your last move okay so bishop g5
this is
a red alert moment right now and you
need to get into the early habit of
especially early on in your chest
development asking yourself what the
threat is so what is he threatening with
his last move
uh the movie just made with the bishop
he's he's threatening my queen
um so he can take the queen uh either if
i
take him or if i do nothing so exactly i
think
my initial reaction is i need to put a
piece in the path of the queen i don't i
should not be moving
that's exactly right because you want to
simultaneously be developing your pieces
so there's many ways of doing that
several good moves what comes to mind
and you can make a couple things this
this one came to mind
initially perfect that's a great move
simultaneously defending against the
threat and developing your peace
which is the ideal way of defending
against any type of threat he's probably
going to take your bishop
and then you're going to already start
thinking in advance about what you want
to take that bishop with
which maybe your kind of intuition is
already suggesting
okay so that's good he just moved it
back so he wasted an entire
like move right and helps you develop
absolutely
um so that's pretty good for me um
now i have to figure out what i'm gonna
do here so i can't
i think i'll i'll do that that's a great
move keep on developing
um tuck your king away so he's again
he's moved his queen out he's lost the
tempo
tempo just means basically move um in
chess he's lost a move with his bishop
and uh you have a lead in development
here so you've got a great position out
of the open woo
okay okay very aggressive russian
very aggressive i don't that doesn't
really
yeah that doesn't track for me like okay
i guess he's threatening to pawn
but like i can trade and if i take the
his pawn
um with my um
knight uh am i stupid i feel like that's
free
it is i i'm gonna do it i always second
guess myself because
i've been in so many situations where
i'd be like oh this is the play and then
it all becomes obvious after the fact
right checks yeah yeah exactly
exactly oh no and then as soon as you
release the piece you see it but here
in reality it is free um and
there is this balance between second
guessing yourself on the one hand and
being
confident of the other it's a natural
progression you're just gonna get more
confident
as you get your feet under you um and as
you come to know
more strategies you'll see that
oftentimes your opponent doesn't want to
do anything at all
yeah uh he kind of yeah i'm not really
sure what that's supposed to accomplish
that that pawn to h4 to be honestly
called me neither
so i'm gonna you're kind of safe yep
excellent
now with full due respect to most of
your opponents
i would say probably 50 to 75 of their
moves have no intention behind them at
all so you can kind of safely proceed
the key for you right now is the
identification of threats as long as you
can identify what your opponent is
threatening if he's threatening
something
and not blunder pieces that is sort of
going to be the first
serious step forward that you make that
in combination with applying basic
strategies of opening a middle game
that's going to bring you to like 7 800
which is
you know already it might seem to be in
this in the stratosphere right now but
i can already i know they're underrated
i know that that's not very high but uh
yeah i
uh it's much higher than i am now so i'm
i'm i'm ready i'm ready to get there
i'm eager to get there yeah when i was
okay 95
so okay so talk about identifying
threats
he's he's threatening tonight my night
at uh
at c6 but there's lots of trade
potentials there so it kind of comes out
even before this move was made i was
already thinking about putting my queen
at d6
uh i don't know if that changes this
uh well you mentioned taking the knight
right
what yeah try to forecast what happens
there if you take his knight
with one of your knights what is what
does he do
uh he trades with his pawn that's
currently at d4
and then we have these pawns staring at
each other at e5 and e6
kind of rocks but if you count the
number of attackers
that are currently accessing that e5
square do you see that both of your
knights are actually contesting that
square
now i do and only now
of his is defending that score which
means by definition he's essentially
blundered something on that square
right so i can come out um upon ahead
in this bingo this trade bingo which is
not
the end of the world for him but notice
that while you've been developing your
pieces
he's been pushing his pawns around so
not only do you have two extra pawns now
but you have a tremendous lead in
development which you could then
use um to transform it into either an
attack
or pressure against his position a lead
in development is a huge asset
that as you get more experience you're
going to come to appreciate and kind of
know how to exploit
yeah i think that's one of my really
serious issues is i'll get
leads like this often right where i'm up
a piece or two
or whatever and then after that i'm kind
of like oh [ __ ] like
what do i how do i take advantage of
that other than just
you know playing move to move totally
get it that's actually
one of the that is like what i will put
the emphasis on initially and this is a
great time to
start probing that you have this lead in
development what to do now
what comes to your mind well he just
retreated retreated as queen which
is kind of interesting uh trying to
control this d line
uh but i mean i'm not i'm not too
worried about that right now
i i want to develop like i want to bring
out this bishop
c uh c8 or or the queen
so i'm kind of thinking this
good move good move activating the queen
and you know after the game i'll share
with you sort of the finer points i'm
taking down some notes as to your
thinking process
but by and large you're doing everything
good so far
yeah he's he's his board state is really
underdeveloped
it's not really looking that great for
him just i just
i'm sure i will blunder very soon i'm
sure i will even even up the score
it's all good he's developed his knight
uh nothing immediately
threatening so i kind of want to bring
this bishop out
if i can so i i i want to do this
personally okay so you want to pave open
that b7 square for the bishop is that
your idea
yeah that's right that's a nice idea
that's called fianchettoing the bishop
there is actually a term for that
putting them on that particular square
i've heard this term and uh i didn't
know what it meant
so that's good
yeah and notice that your bishop is now
positioned on what's called the long
diagonal
there are two long diagonals the ones
that crisscross the entire board
and obviously you measure how good a
piece is
among other things by the amount of
squares that it controls the bishop
controls a lot of squares
as we'll see but red alert what does he
want to do
red alert okay now he's he's i was
already thinking about how i can clear
the path for my bishop to take his rook
but now i've got a bigger problem in
front of me i have my knight is being
threatened by the pawn
i got to get this guy out of here
exactly
gotta get this guy out of here now where
do you put it there's many good squares
yeah c4 is interesting because it's like
baiting out a trade i don't really
know if that gets me anywhere in the
long run
so i'm inclined to be more conservative
and like maybe go g4
good uh i think i'll do that that's a
great square
um there's an advanced chess concept
um that we're not going to touch on too
much today that's called an outpost
but i can kind of introduce it to you
and an outpost
is it's a relatively self
self-explanatory concept it's when a
piece is
like past the fifth rank past the
hemisphere and it's supported by a pawn
as the knight is
and the key element of an outpost is
that it cannot be dislodged by one of
your opponent's pawns because both of
them
have moved past the square where they
can attack the knight but another red
alert
he's made a somewhat inadvisable little
move there
okay so what has he done
here move that pawn up i guess to
support his other pawn i don't really
know
why i mean i guess i was threatening
with the queen right
see the thing that i can't get out of my
head is i want to move my pawn
that's on d5 up and like okay it'll get
taken like whatever
but then i can threaten his his rook
that's a fantastic move
that is a fantastic move i want to do
that and
obviously he'll see that so he won't
even take the pawn i think he might
if i know the mentality of these players
he might actually think oh this colin
guy who's this colin mcneil he's
blundering pawns left and right
maybe he'll see it i mean you you've
played opponents like these but i think
he just might take that pawn
i'm gonna bet he sees it i will bet you
he sees it he might see let's see
oh my god you were right i've
been around i don't even understand
amazing move and i the thing is d4 is
the best move in the position if he
would have moved
his rook he would have taken his pawn
and we we you know we'll discuss that
afterward
okay so he takes that pawn um
consolation prize for him yeah but a
small one
very small he's not threatening anything
i can uh i actually kind of want to move
this
this rook that's currently at a8 to b um
i can threaten his bishop and also the
rook and do something he's just kind of
like tucked away over there
okay are there anything that uh-huh
sorry yeah
is there no no no no no that was the
other thing that's my initial and that's
that's something you need to get into
the habit of asking yourself is there
anything
hanging whether it's pieces or pawns
that you could just capture anything
that's free
there is the pawn at e3 that is
definitely free
for my night snatch it up i don't know
if you've had your lunch yet but
there's no such thing as too much
material on the chessboard
very true okay okay let's do that thanks
cappy for the subs appreciate it man
yep and notice that what is the knight
doing there
other than you know chilling he's uh
threatening the queen
which is pretty serious business now
look this guy's gonna have to deal
yeah he's gonna have to deal with that
and also look at well he did deal with
it
um now he's attacking your knight and
the best types of chess moves are the
ones where you
capture something that's free and defend
something that's being attacked at the
same time
right is there a way to affect that
there i think his his pawn at d4
if i take it with my queen i defend the
knight
yeah i think that works it does very
nice for that
look at his king his king is wide open
and
most of the games at your level most of
the games you play up until
your 1300 which is a thousand points
from now
are going to be decided by a direct
attack on the king well
that's not entirely accurate they're
going to be decided in one of two ways
either by a blunder or by direct attack
in the king but you're low on time i
don't want to distract you he's given
you a check
okay let's
do that very nice defending the bishop
and defending against the check
simultaneously good move
okay he's out of there he's he's had
enough
he has um
threatening no not really uh okay what
should i do here
when in doubt check for free stuff there
is a
free pawn and a check that goes with it
check that lottery ticket now he's gonna
move his king up to e2
start thinking about what threats he
creates when he brings his king up
is he threatening any of your pieces
then well he's not really threatening
the knight because i have the knight
covered he can't he can't take it
actually he is because he's attacking it
with two of his pieces the king and the
queen and you're only defending it with
one it's one against two right king
does participate as an attacker here so
you have to evacuate that uh
or could i do this
good idea but not concretely oh
they're your blunder there's your
blunder that i guaranteed you
okay now i'm satisfied so i was about to
say where is that blunders promise
calling
oh it's right there now i don't have to
leave the call anymore but
not to panic is he attacking any of your
pieces other than the knight
oh he's attacking the rook but i mean
it's it's it's
you gotta well the rook is pinned you
cannot move the rope you have
only one possible move in this position
you have to simultaneously defend the
knight while intercepting
his queen's attack of your rook there is
one move that serves both purposes
and there's only one move that does that
he's attacking your rook with this queen
and we'll unpack this after the game for
now
try to consult your instincts here oh
boy that's a bad move for me usually
man uh
you have to move that knight somewhere
there is a particular square where you
intercept the queen's coverage
of your rook yup very nice
very very nice and even though he can
take a second rook his king is still
very very exposed so in reality your
position is not that bad
believe it or not nice move okay
i'm definitely gonna flag this game
this happens to me a lot
that's totally okay and the important
thing is that you're playing a good game
you're still winning in this position
he is attacking your queen and you moved
it very very good
yeah he actually defended pretty well
there that's a good move as well
but now he can take your knight yeah and
there i go i lose
see this is this is my problem up on all
these pieces i feel like i'm in a good
spot
and because i take too long and or i do
one blunder and i freak out and then
i just i flag totally understand so
you're probably here to jump in for
another game but my proposal is
i will invite you to oops wait a second
sorry
i will invite you to i keep getting
random skype calls i will invite you to
an analysis board
um which will pop up and if you're okay
with that and
i want to unpack a couple of moments
there so we'll delve right into that
thing that makes you anxious which is
well what the heck do you do when you
reach that good position
um now uh for my for my producer on on
the call here colton can you see the
analysis board
so i i'll actually invite me as well
if you click on it uh colin you should
it should pop up on your screen
um and i'm inviting you right now in a
moment
okay okay so you'll see the invite pop
up should be on the lower right of your
screen
um colin mcneil
just sent the invite so perfect got that
and then and then colton do you need an
invite to this as well
yeah sorry daniel we're streaming it for
maya no problem so the stream actually
sees my screen
could you could you give me your um
chess.com
uh account name colin can you uh can you
put it in the discord call and i can't
minimize mine
yeah uh wait what
no no no this is totally fine it's kind
of like our like weird method of
streaming
we're streaming it from like our my
producers like you guys are professional
i just i just want to do as little work
as possible that's all
i want to focus on the chess if i can my
guy exactly
all right where do i find all my friends
here so i can give them your name
what is it colton you just said it's
colton g colton g
e and not o n g one
is it case sensitive i don't think so
okay capital c and g though full 10g
that's what i that's what i put in yeah
inviting you right now just sent you
that invite
beautiful amazing now sometimes fair
warning the
analysis interface might glitch um and
the moves might stop transmitting from
my ntor and so
if that happens just let me know like
sometimes i'll be making moves and
you'll stop seeing them that's just a
chess.com glitch
uh that happens once in a while
hopefully it won't happen here now can
you see me actually
relaying the moves and clicking through
some of the moves yep
perfect got it awesome so um
the start of the game was actually
fantastic and
stop me if at any moment i'm drawing on
too long i'll try to be succinct
um but a couple of things that i want to
unpack
number one in terms of the actual
mechanics of peace development
um one of the most common mistakes that
that you'll find yourself making
is and it'll introduce a concept called
tunnel vision that's going to help you
conceptualize
that but preliminarily oftentimes you
think about developing one piece
and by trying to develop one piece you
thereby block the development of another
piece now
how this works is you played this movie
six right
and you're opening up the diagonal for
this bishop
right but do you notice that you're also
closing down the diagonal for your other
bishop
yes so this bishop only has this lame
little square on d7 to go to
which is not a terrible way of
developing it but it's not very active
right it doesn't control as many squares
as it could
so what move could you suggest here
so that when you do play e6 you don't
actually block this bishop on c8
uh the bishop to f5 exactly and you can
actually make moves
um i should be able to see them i'm also
keeping an eye on your stream so
if the transmission stops i'll be able
to catch that
okay so i just made that move which
hopefully you guys see
um sometimes i need to like nudge it a
couple of times so i i manually put a
bishop f5 that's exactly right or bishop
g4
then let's say he develops his own
bishop then you play the movie six
and the bishop is outside of the pawn
chain then you can very safely develop
the other bishop
you see what i'm saying yes so in
general when you're developing
you want to make sure that when you're
preparing the development of one piece
you're not blocking the development of
another that's something that's going to
take some practice and you're going to
make that mistake a couple times
but it's just a good rule of thumb to
keep in mind not that e6 is that bad
um so here you played above f5 what was
sort of the rationale
behind this movie if you had to sort of
reconstruct it
there wasn't a lot of rationale other
than just the concept of
i want to go into the middle of the
board and i knew that that pawn was
going to be protected by the pawn of e6
and so i thought well let me let's just
grab this territory for the sake of
grabbing it
that's interesting so it's not a bad
move um
the reason that you have to be careful
about pushing pawns in general is that
pushing any kind of pawn by definition
creates weaknesses
behind it so when you push the pawn from
f7
do you notice how the king you know it's
like the king is riding in the back seat
of the car
and you've pulled the windows down
you've opened up the diagonal
you've opened up some squares and the
problem is that if you ever castle
short the fact that you've pushed this
pawn out
might actually cost you because again
you've opened up some avenues
potentially toward that black king
um right so does that make sense
conceptually
that that makes a lot of sense that's
actually super helpful because
i have noticed in my games i am as you
say pushing pawns
a lot like i'm developing the pawns all
the time and
and just even to someone uh who is
you know has as as low rating as i do
even i understand that like
okay listen they're not the most
powerful piece they're the weakest
piece like you should put your more
powerful pieces out there so that's good
for me to
to hear hear it the way you put it like
that exactly and
it's the way that i've come to explain
this is
like it's not that pushing pawns out is
inherently bad but it's like i'm
teaching you to drive a car but you're
insisting on learning how to drive a bus
before you're learning how to drive a
car like ponds are
very niche pieces and they're very hard
to handle so
the first step is to learn peace
placement and that is why
even if you're tempted to push pawns out
for the next
you know couple of months that you're
playing for the next couple of hundreds
of points that you gain
i think that you should sort of
consciously prioritize playing with the
pieces and only push pawns
when you would know exactly what role
that is serving like if you make a pawn
move i should be able to ask you colin
why did you make this move you say well
i wanted to control the square
i wanted to defend against the threat i
wanted to chase away this piece
um this move is more sort of kind of up
in the air i kind of wanted to control
some squares
but it creates a lot of weaknesses
behind it if that's right
that does make sense i've actually just
opened up a little document and
written that down like prioritized
pushing pizzas not pawns
that is that is diligent
um i am probably the laziest grandmaster
you'll ever meet so
i'm always impressed at people's work
ethic especially when
beginning chess is just there's so much
to talk about and you're you're lost at
sea
so i appreciate your attitude i think
it's it's going to take you far
so i hope so my skill won't
it that'll come trust it'll all come
together you just have to have faith so
this was all great you developed your
bishop you developed your knight g4 is
just a free pawn
um now you could have also taken that
pawn with your pawn that would have been
very much possible and do you see that
you would have simultaneously created a
threat here
yes uh what are you threatening
uh threatening his knight with that pawn
threatening his night with that pawn so
in order to practice
uh one concept that i want to give you a
little bit of practice in which is
counting defenders and attackers let's
say that he would have responded
by pushing his knight out to e5 first
and foremost
can you take this knight with your
knight
yes i can take it with the knight at c6
for some reason
the chess.com software is glitching it
won't allow me to execute that move
i'm kidding actually it's illegal i'm
kidding
i'm just trolling you why is the knight
is the move knight 65 illegal
is it actually illegal it actually is
illegal because of what
a concept called the pin
pin the queen on a4 what can you tell me
about it what is it doing
what is its relationship to the black
kids oh of course i can't
i can't move my knight out of there i i
understand he's he's pinned by the queen
and by by your use of that term i
imagine you've you've been introduced to
that concept in general right the
concept of opinion yeah
i've seen it in uh in in various videos
from you
and hikaru and bhopez and so on right
and and you can think of it
more abstractly as any situation where a
piece cannot move away from a square for
any particular
reason it doesn't have to be most people
confuse it
and they think oh it's only a pin
against the king if the queen was
sitting on e8 instead of the king
um well then the knight could legally
move but in many cases that wouldn't be
very advisable you don't want to give
away your queen
right so one corollary to that and it's
a little bit advanced but i think it's a
good rule of thumb
um the lesser value a piece is the
better
the better it is at actually making a
pin which sounds like a very paradoxical
statement but let me unpack that for you
for a second
let's imagine a scenario i'm just going
to make some random moves to to paint
that picture
let's imagine a scenario where black's
queen is on e8
you see this relationship right right
now
is the knight on c6 actually pinned the
answer to that question
is no because let's say white makes a
random move and you capture the knight
does white win a queen here with queen
takes ea
is white winning material no it's a
straight trade it's a straight trade
but if a lesser value piece is spinning
this knight
then it's much less likely to be a
straight trade so could you orchestrate
an actual valuable pin with one of your
pieces against the knight on c6
if i'm white if you're white yeah
white's a move in this position
yeah i move the bishop to b5 bingo
that's exactly right and now if the
knight takes on e5
because the bishop is lesser value it's
a lot more painful for black black loses
a queen for a bishop which is huge
yes so does that kind of make sense so
the queen is still pinning the knight
this is a pin because there's a king
behind the knight but if there was a
queen behind the knight this wouldn't
have been as effective of a pin
so with all of that in mind in this
position
could you find instead of the move
knight f6 that you played
a move to disarm this pin and actually
turn the spin
back around on white
turn it back around that shows you
exactly why
they say don't bring your queen out
early the queen
isn't good at doing the dirty work
because okay it's too valuable to be
given up so as soon as it's
in danger the queen loses its potency
could you put this queen in danger
by creating something called an x-ray
an x-ray and it's kind of actually a
reverse pin it's like
it's not quite a pin but it's when one
of your pieces
stares down an opponent's piece through
the lens of another piece
or through
the scope of another piece well
uh i'm not 100 sure if this is where
this is going but
could you you can move the bishop that's
on c82 uh
to d7 that is exactly right and what
would be the idea what am i talking
about in terms of x-ray
so bishop is staring down that queen
like just forget about the night for a
second it's like almost looking over the
night
bingo and that is a very powerful
concept because if the knight ever moves
away
even if the knight sacrifices itself
let's say white in all his infinite
wisdom plays knight e5
and black takes the knight the the sort
of x-ray has opened up can white
take the knight back with his pawn
i mean he definitely can't unless he
wants to give me a free queen exactly
which he doesn't but many people
actually will so that would be
an effective defensive mechanism just
wanted to kind of
point that out but i know you're anxious
to get to sort of the technical phase
now here again
whenever your opponent places a piece on
a square where it can be captured
you want to also get into the habit of
counting defenders and attackers
and to do that you have to look at the
whole board because
i mentioned tunnel vision earlier i
hinted at that concept tunnel vision is
a concept
i use um to refer to
situations where and this usually refers
to beginners but even
i can do it sometimes the action is
occurring on one side of the board
usually so your eyes are like literally
drawn to that particular side of the
board and it's very easy to forget
that there exist pieces that are on the
opposite side of the board that are also
participating in the action
so here for example i'll delineate the
area of the board that
you're most likely to be looking at
right this because this is what i was
this is where you
sacked upon and you're forgetting about
this night because it's outside of that
zone
and you have to make a conscious effort
at least for the first couple of months
to look at the whole board to appreciate
how each and every piece
is participating in the game even if
it's outside of the immediate zone of
action
um if that makes sense it does and i'm
also writing this down because i
definitely tunnel vision i mean that's
where the blunders come from right it's
like
somebody comes out of nowhere it's not
nowhere but
it mentally for me it's like whoa how
did that happen well it was staring you
right in the face you just were looking
at this
quadrant of the board for all the
reasons you stated exactly
and that is in fact one of the biggest
sources of blunders and i have
if you think that gm's are immune from
that absolutely not true i remember
i was rated about 2000 and i had a game
where i took a pawn with one with with
one of my bishops right
and he has a rook somewhere so i took
this a7 pawn that i highlighted in red
and the other highlight was where his
rook was and there were no pieces
on the seventh rank his other rook was
on aa
and i took the pawn i get up i walk
around i'm i won a pawn i'm feeling good
then i come back down and on his score
sheet you know the place where
you have to write down the notation
during over the poor chess games
my opponent records the move that he's
about to play and he records the move
rook g
takes a seven and i'm like rook she
takes this does he want to give away a
rook for a bishop like is he
is he dumb and then he grabs the rook
that's on g7 and takes my bishop and i
literally fell out of my chair
i had completely excommunicated that
rook from my
visual understanding of the position so
it happens to very strong players as
well don't feel discouraged about it
okay
so that's heartening that's very
heartening yeah exactly
gm's are pretty bad too um that's
basically the lesson here so
queen d1 and now we get to the meat now
we get to what
you really need work on which is what do
you do when you reach
these types of overwhelming positions
now what you did here is perfect b5
fiancee the bishop putting the bishop on
a very active square
has a great amount of potential so far
so good
he continues to push response up so
instead of developing his pieces he
continues to introduce
more and more weaknesses in his position
so is that kind of making sense so far
it is making sense so far yeah the move
knight g4 is really good
to finish off that concept of the
outpost because
do you see that this knight cannot be
dislodged by any of his pawns
why because he's pushed both of the
potential pawns
to the same rank that the knight is on
so these pawns can't land on h3 or f3 as
the
expression goes pawns do not go backward
and this is why
it's so risky to push too many of your
pawns precisely because it creates
all of these holes in his position
so knight g4 was perfect now after e3
you found an amazing move d4
but could you have also taken any free
stuff here
so the pawn he just pushed to e3
would be free for my knight it is and
you're attacking a queen
you did that a little bit later so one
thing you need to get a little bit more
confident at is just taking that free
stuff you're constantly running those
diagnostic tests in the background of
your mind
is there free stuff did my opponent
blunder any pieces
i i tunnel vision right that's what i
did because
several moves before that i was thinking
about my bishop's line of attack
and i was like oh i'm gonna get that
rook right and i just
forgot about everything else that's
exactly what it is but i want to point
out your move d4
is also really good because had he moved
his rook away
what would you what would you have done
now
now i can take the pawn that's e3 with
the pawn i just pushed which also
threatens his knight and
let's practice finishing me off in this
position let's say that he moves his
knight away
for instance to b3 now don't be
intimidated by
all of the stuff that's going on here
you still need to apply fundamental
thinking patterns
is there anything that you could take
here and
ideally also prepare to checkmate him
right um
okay i'm looking for two potential moves
i'd like you to name both of them
there's two things that you can take
here
which constitute free stuff free stuff
okay we like free stuff exactly yeah
yeah now you're gonna see it
my bishop to d5
are you taking anything nope that's
that's not free at all
that's not free that's a trade it's
literally a capture yeah you could
capture the queen that's a trade
but you don't necessarily want to do
that that doesn't no i don't want to do
that and and i was thinking like
i moved my bishop the one that's at um
b7
to uh d5 and threatened the knight but
that's that's a trade
too because his uh queen is covering
that right so you're not actually
threatening that that's that's another
thing
in your minds it might be pedantic of me
to say this but
like you should only reserve the word
threatening for when
literally you're threatening to capture
a piece and you win material
this is yeah no it's not attached it's
not a threat at all it's just a straight
trade we just thinned the board
exactly
h4 is free for sure bingo uh with my
bishop
and you said you kind of you gave it
away to me he said the other one is a
pawn too which is
the pawn at f4 exactly exactly
i was tunnel visioning even now i wasn't
looking at those because i'm just like
oh those pawns are they're they're not
doing anything like they're useless like
he's wasted them i'm not even going to
look at them
i want to look at his this weird back
line he has
and this knight that's surrounded by
pawns like i'm looking in
i'm pointing as if you can see where i'm
pointing but you know like this this
back triangle of the board
exactly it's like you've you know you've
you've been on some desert island
subsisting on
fruit for like three weeks and you come
in and you've come to like golden corral
and you're looking at the steak and the
salmon like what do i what do i even do
man there's so much going on here i
could take his queen
ooh i could attack his knight and this
is a completely
normal part of the process um and the
better you get you just get calmer about
looking at these positions i look at
this position i don't see chaos
i see these hanging pawns and i see the
very weak king so
let's say you capture on h4 what
additional benefit does this move have
can you can he take your queen
no he's in check so he has to do he has
to move his uh or block his king do
something
he has to move his king out and this is
where
i'll introduce you well i'm sure you
understand and know the concept
of tactics um have you talked about that
i guess how much have you talked about
that with robert and the other people of
train with the concept of chess tactics
not very not very much i don't think so
tactics um and i'm sure you've heard
that word thrown around
essentially the easiest way to
conceptualize it
is tactics is anything that aims to do
one of two things
checkmate the king or win material
any move that falls under that umbrella
is a tactic anything that
aims to accomplish that is a tactic and
tactics are going to be the building
blocks
on which you're going to build the
foundation of your chest development
and in this position you're going to
find your very first tactic
and i'm going to guide you to it do you
see the screen on d1
what is it defended by uh it's defended
by the
king bingo and that is it that is it
that is a warning sign for white because
hypothetically
you can envision a scenario where by
means of some sort of mouse trap
you ward the king off from its defense
of the queen
and then i think i see queen i think i
see where we're going
um if i move one of my rooks to d8
and i cover that file with two
with two i can take his queen for free
that's great thinking except you're
missing one problem it's white to mophie
my friend so he's gonna take your coin
before you take his
oh so tactics not only
do you have to make this happen but you
also have to make this happen with check
you have to do something where he
actually cannot take your queen
and instead he has to move his king away
and there is a move that serves all
these purposes
i have to do something where he can't
take my queen
uh but but i put him in check sorry it's
a check yes you're looking for a check
and the purpose served by this check is
that and remember with tactics
and with chess in general it's a game of
tit for tech
sometimes you need to sacrifice a little
bit to gain a lot and that is part of
the reason why this move is not
occurring to you right now because
in your minds you see the square you see
that you could land a piece on that
square
but not to put words in your mouth but
you're probably thinking well this
square is covered i can't put my beast
there
but it's covered by none other than the
king which is also covering the queen so
the king is said to be overloaded
okay would that square be d3 no
no because the queen's covering that
right and you can't use your
own queen toward the king it has to be
an external piece
and this is another case where you're
also probably tunnel visioning this d
file you think it's something related to
this d file but
yeah it's actually not you're using a
piece that you expertly put
on a particularly active square
to check him it's a check it's a check i
know this is tough but
i want you to find this move this is
going to be a significant milestone this
is going to be your first tactic
so keep at it okay so if i put
the bishop my bishop that's currently on
b7
to f3 that checks him
um and
he's got to take your bishop and why
don't i take it
now it's my initiative i can take the
queen the king's out of position to
defend her
bingo so now that's a free queen that's
that's it congratulations you just found
your first tactic bishop f3 check
sacrificing the bishop
forcing the king prying the king away
from the queen
now nothing is defending the queen free
queen
check and notice how many pieces you
have in the attack you're gonna pick
this king off
in the next couple of moves uh it's so
frustrating that it took me so long to
see
one single linear move
but this is your first one of its
category and it all gets
asymptotically exponentially faster
after that so
as a second question let's say he moves
his king away what is the simplest move
here
remember the key question before you do
anything else is there any free stuff
that you could take
free stuff okay
i mean i can't i can't really take those
bishops up there because they're covered
by the rooks so that's definitely not
free right but the knight at b3 is free
is yes exactly so your priority for the
next couple of games is literally going
to be
can you quickly and efficiently identify
free stuff
and can you take it that's going to be
like the one and only goal i know that
sounds like
i'm seriously putting the training
wheels on but if you can do that
sort of your mission has been
accomplished everything else is extra
credit
yeah i mean that sounds like training
wheels i i need
you i desperately need that's why a lot
of people quit just like this is i wanna
i want action you know i wanna
attack i wanna checkmate and they hear
their coach saying you know you have to
like
do this lame thing where you like count
the number of pieces uh that's like i'm
doing something else but that's like a
necessary step of the process so
just to conclude this analysis you were
actually doing
everything right up until this moment
yeah
and rookie conceptual is a great move
the only problem is it blunders the rook
yeah so when you have a position like
this with an open board
a lot of pieces out on various squares
you just have to do that blunder check
ask yourself is my move of blunder now
you were low on time here which is okay
now knowing what you know now could you
do something a little bit safer
where you simply move this knight away
from e3
all right move the knight away um
i could yeah i could put him i mean
doesn't accomplish anything but
get him out of harm's way but i can move
him to g4
right or d5 i also like the idea of
moving what is this called again what is
this relationship here
pin pin you don't want pins lying around
like if you can eliminate pins
you want to eliminate things not all
pins are scary
but a lot of them are so where could you
put this knight
to eliminate that pin simultaneously
right well you you just helped me cheat
a little bit i think with that d5 yeah
exactly
i tried to slip that under the covers
but knight t5 eliminates the pin
wide open king and final thing i want to
do is
help you kind of formulate a way let's
say you would have played knight t5 and
your opponent would have played
a random move like bishop c6 now
this is where um you kind of have to go
from
i'm completely winning like i'm up a
rook at some point you have to make the
decision
to launch the final invasion and to kind
of launch the final attack
but you don't have to hurry with that
and that's the key point that i want to
make
what you want to emphasize and
prioritize is just getting pieces out of
harm's way so is he threatening any
piece here
uh yes he's threatening my rook at a8
where could you put that rook so that it
at least aims somewhere in the direction
of that king so that it's at least
in the action e8 would check the king
but you're blundering again that he can
take that rook it's the exact same thing
i didn't even do the problem i set you
up for that
that's my bad no
i failed the test oh f that's an f
oh man okay not ea but you're close
slightly better square okay um
and you said that it would it would
threaten the king
it's not that it would threaten the king
but one thing that you want to do with
rooks
are you familiar with the concept of
well you're familiar with the concept of
a file right like this
rooks are best on open files an open
file
as you can probably intuit is a file
that has no pawns on it which means the
rook is operating uncontested
so which open file near the center can
you put the rook on
with no pawns on it that's the
definition of an oh that is the
definition of an open file
a file that has and there's gradations
of that definition but that is the pure
definition of an open file right okay so
when i look at d8 like
initially that file looks very crowded
to me it actually doesn't look like my
rook can do much at all because i'm i've
got two pieces sort of taking up space
there already
but here's the key insight if you put
the rook on c8
pawns are a lot harder to remove bonds
are a lot more immobile than a piece is
if you put the rook on z8 and this is
another thing you're going to get more
comfortable with
is seeing stuff in the long term this is
what you pointed out to me in the
beginning you know
you feel like you're seeing two steps
you can't see how how are these pieces
going to clear themselves
but the reality is all that i have to do
is move my knight away and the queen and
the rook are linked on an open file and
that is a fearsome combination
so is that sort of making sense from a
general perspective
it is it is it is it worries me because
i i
don't think i would have got there
without you pushing me there so
at first it does make sense but now you
will so let's say he moves his queen
away
somewhere um this is probably the
hardest part this is going to be the
hardest part of your early improvement
it you know in terms of charlie you
mentioned that you watched a couple
videos this is also charlie's biggest
weakness and he's right at a thousand
and he still struggles with this so this
is going to be frustrating
um and there's just no way around it the
concept of actually finishing your
opponent off when you're
two or three moves away from checkmate
so yes
can you find any potential checking
squares
with your queen near his king
and use the pieces in the center like
use the knight see which squares the
knight is defending
and see if you can put the queen on one
of those defended squares
and shove this game back toward the
corner yeah immediately i i see
e3 brilliant queen e3 check
he has two pots and possible moves and
both of them get checkmated with the
same response let's say king to d1
can you find the checkmate in one
let's see if i can
so i guess it's as simple as the queen
to f2
that's not a check though right no it's
not it just means he can't move his king
but he doesn't have to he's not under
pressure
right he his king is already immobilized
so as long as you don't
well it has to be a track and it has to
keep these two squares under control
and yes this is a great application this
is a great example of anti-tunnel vision
where
one of the pieces that participates in
this mate is a piece that you might have
kind of forgotten about it like
it's got to be that bishop at h4 right
because i know he's covering
e1 exactly and which piece could you put
on e1
the queen exactly this is checkmate and
you're beginning to sense that
relationship between the pieces
this bishop is you know the queen is
dangling the queen like a marionette
and the king is checkmated so this
is one of the most difficult skills like
you're on the cusp of checkmating
actually finding that checkmating
sequence this is where
solving puzzles actually comes in this
is why you probably heard of that as a
training method
um and that is why it's so important to
solve puzzles but we'll get to that i
don't want to overwhelm you
for now what are the key insights from
this game first of all your top priority
developing your pieces in a healthy
fashion remember that
pushing your pawns out forward should
not be your top priority you should
prioritize peace placement
number two when you're developing a
piece make sure you're not blocking the
development of another piece
such as the movie six number three
and number four number five all at the
same time your number one priority right
now
looking for free stuff capturing it
and identifying the threats that your
opponent is posing and defending against
them
if you just do those two things a lot of
correct moves will just materialize
naturally
[Music]
you